[موسيقى]
الثلاجات في المتاجر كبيره قوي السوبر
ماركت عاده ما تحتوي على كل ما هو طازج
وايضا المجمدات من اللحوم والخضروات ولكن
الخضروات في هذه الثلاجه زرعت هنا
وباستخدام المياه فقط بدون تربه
[موسيقى]
ثلاجه الزراعه المائيه تقنيه جديده توفر
في كميه المياه وتوفر ايضا منتجات طازجه
[موسيقى]
تقنيات حديثه في الزراعه تتماشى مع سياسه
ترشيد المياه وتوضع الشتلات هنا داخل
الثلاجه ويتم امدادها بالمياه فتنه داخل
المتجر ويستطيع الشخص شراءها طازجه تماما
وكانها خرجت من الارض
ممكن توصل ل 90% من الميه اللي بتستخدم في
ريا النباتات ده رقم واحد
التربه التقليديه اللي بيحصل في زراعه
التقليديه ان الحاجه بتزرع في اراضي
زراعيه بره المدينه
الى المدينه المكان عندك
النقل في فاقد بيحصل في المنتجات نفسها ده
كل ده بيقدر نقصه عن طريق الزراعه المائيه
اللي بتتم في مكان بيع او استهلاك المنتج
[موسيقى]
لو هنتكلم عن الطعم احنا برده في الزراعه
المائيه عندنا تحكم كامل في اللي بتديني
النبات كمغزيات هنقدر نطلع طعم فريش اكثر
كثير من الزراعه التقليديه
[موسيقى]
يعني احسن ما تيجي حاجه مغلفه
هو احد مشاريع شركه اسسها الرواد في مجال
الاستدامه والحفاظ على البيئه والتي تشارك
في قمه المناخ بشرم الشيخ هو احنا مهتمين
بزراعه الحديثه بشكل عام ومتهمين ان احنا
ندخل الزراعه الحديثه في كل الاماكن اللي
ممكن ندخلها فيها
بدايه من ان احنا ندخل الزراعه في بيوت
الناس باستخدام طرق برده حديثه الى
المزارع الكبيره الضخمه ان احنا ندخل فيها
مثلا طرق ان احنا نشوف مثلا استهلاك
المياه بطريقه ذكيه بنستخدم مثلا
بنستعين بمعلومات بناخذها من مرسى صناعيه
بتديني معلومات عن صحه النبات وعن صحه
الارض وهكذا الزراعه الذكيه يمكن ان تتابع
في مزارع كبيره وايضا في المنازل على نطاق
صغير عندنا ترابيزه منزليه دي ممكن الواحد
بيستخدمها في البيت عنده همم بيزرع فيها
كل الحاجات اللي هو عايز يزرعها او من
ناحيه ال- اا ورقيات
فممكن يزرع فيها مثلا خاص جرجير ممكن يزرع
فيها سبانخ وكل اللي هي الورقيات فده
يعتبر منتج للمنزل يعني فمش مكلف يوما بعد
يوم يتوسع الشباب في استخدام التكنولوجيا
للحفاظ على الموارد الطبيعيه التي اصبحت
محل قلق في جميع انحاء العالم سمر باشات
لصباح العربيه من القاهره